notre série sur les 35 heures les temps
libre une nouvelle organisation du
travail qui permet à certains de vivre
pleinement leur passion extra
professionnelles c'est le cas de cet
employé des services culturels de la
ville de nantes qui n'a d'yeux que pour
ses abeilles le reportage sur place de
jean martial jean k et jean pierre brais
nichons côté pile un agent maintien au
service culturel de la ville de nantes
loïc leray côté face un apiculteur
toujours loïc leray point de vue on le
vit juste une passion parfaitement
assumé
on va essayer de trouver la reine
d'accord on va payer encore mieux depuis
que loïc et aux 35 heures désormais un
lundi sur deux ces suppléments abeilles
voir un petit peu de famine
ça me permet donc de se consacrer encore
plus à ma passion qui est l'appli
culture et quelque part donc ça ça
permet d'être un peu plus aussi avec la
famille donc pour nous
et moi en l'occurrence je trouve que
c'est une chose extraordinaire président
des apiculteurs de loire atlantique
le hic profite à plein de ce temps
supplémentaire son nouveau projet
l'installation d'un rucher en plein
centre ville nantais au pied de la butte
sainte-anne dix ruches sur 18 hectares
de nature cachée afin d'éduquer petit
gant citadins d'où un surcroît de
travail et un maître mot organisations
voilà l'occurrence celle apiculteurs
mais j'ai d'autres codecs et qui
s'intéresse à la pêche aux ou à la
peinture
donc c'est il faut quand même mon avis
bien essayé de bien gérer son temps et
passionné
pour bien utiliser j'irai les 35 heures
seul paradoxe si loïc et est apiculteur
professionnel un rêve de passionnés
jamais il n'aurait pu bénéficier des 35
heures je côtoie les professionnels de
loire atlantique et les 35 heures c'est
pas pour demain
et a priori ce n'est pas pour la bei non
plus à les mayas au taf bon